hello
today is a very important day for me
I have become a person that has 1
million subscribers on the website
youtube.com
this is something that I never ever
thought would become a reality but here
we are 11 years ago I started uploading
audio adaptations to this channel
started it with the purpose of creating
audio adaptations of tales or stories on
a website I find even in 2011 had a
massive catalog of work that I enjoyed
reading and helped me express myself at
the time
for the past six years I've been doing
this full time and it's the best job
I've ever had and in all likelihood will
ever have I get to work from home work
on projects that I enjoy and care about
and I have learned the skill and 3D
modeling that I would never have had the
time to learn if not for the environment
that the SCP Wiki and YouTube have
provided me with
this insane milestone for a channel like
mine was all made possible by the
unwavering support of kindless
individuals I want to take a moment to
express my heartfelt appreciation to all
of those who have generously supported
me both financially massive shout out to
my patrons thank you all so much and
those who have shown their Love by
subscribing and unsubscribing I love you
too because you were subscribed at one
point collaborating with me and Sharon
heartwarming messages about how the
content that I've adopted has positively
impacted their lives over the years
this channel has transformed my life in
lots of ways it has opened doors that I
never thought would even be open to me
and for that I will be eternally
grateful but this achievement is not
just mine to clean
it's a collective success
the SCP Wiki and the SCP Foundation
fandom has become something Monumental
over the spawn of its existence these
stories have touched the lives of
millions of people over this time the
beauty of the SCP fandom is that it
isn't made good by just one person it's
made great by everyone involved and
there are so many people involved in
this fandom in no particular order the
author's SCP Wiki staff there are too
many different responsibilities to list
here but you get the idea
illustrators programmers animators
filmmakers video game developers content
creators cosplayers Community managers
the list goes on
let me level with here I know the usual
drill and videos like this is to share
thanks upon ones fans and call it a day
however I want to do something different
with the rest of this particular video
this channel Stands Tall today because
of the dedication and tireless efforts
of hundreds of authors who poured their
hearts and souls into craft and
captivating articles on the SCP Wiki
regardless of the geographical location
of the SCP Wiki you write for these
talented individuals invested not just
days or weeks but often months and years
to perfect their creations and that is
their amazing work that has formed the
very Foundation no pun intended of my
Channel's success since 2012 and
continues to do so
I want to take this opportunity to
extend my deepest gratitude to each and
every SCP author your creativity passion
and talent have captivated the hearts
and minds of countless individuals drawn
them towards the fascinating world of
SCP so from the bottom of my heart I
want to say thank you all so much
thank you for your creativity your
dedication and your generosity thank you
for sharing your incredible imagination
with the world without your amazing
contributions my channel would not exist
and more importantly this fandom would
not exist to anyone watching this video
I urge you to take a moment and show
your appreciation for the incredible SCP
authors who continue to share their
mindless creativity with everyone in the
comments section maybe talk about your
favorite author's article how it
impacted you what stuck with you you
know what I mean if any SCP authors are
watching this let yourselves be known
let's celebrate their contributions for
they are the ones who truly deserve our
admiration and Applause once again thank
you all for being part of this chapter
in my life
there have been ups and downs but there
is one thing for sure I will never
forget the impact that this channel has
had on my life
here's to a million subscribers
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and I'll see you in the next
video
goodbye
[Music]